>> Harris: THE ONLY PROBLEM IS
ME AND THAT PUT AS SPIN ON
THINGS THAT TAYLOR SWIFT COULD
HAVE NEVER SEEN COMING AND
BROWNING HER SILENCE ON THE
TICKETING MISS THAT HAS HER FANS
NOT SHAKING IT OFF.
THE SWIFTIES ARE FURIOUS AT
TICKET MASTER AFTER THAT AND
TRYING TO GET A SEAT AND
TAYLOR'S HIGHLY ANTICIPATED TOUR
AND TICKET MASTER PULLED THE
PLUG ON THE WHOLE THING AND
CANCELED THE GENERAL PUBLIC SALE
OF THE TICKETS.
IT'S BY A SINGLE TICKET
OVERSCALE PER AND THE SITUATION
IS EXCRUCIATING AND A STATEMENT
TO HER FANS.
SHE HAD THIS "THERE'S A
MULTITUDE OF WHY PEOPLE HAD A
HARD TIME TRYING TO GET TICKETS
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW THE
SITUATION CAN BE IMPROVED GOING
FORWARD".
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE EXCUSES
FOR ANYBODY BECAUSE WE ASKED
THEM MULTIPLE TIMES IF THEY
COULD HANDLE THIS KIND OF DEMAND
AND WE WERE ASSURED THEY COULD
BUT THE BAD BLOOD DOESN'T END
THERE.
LAWMAKERS LIKE AOC CALLING FOR
THE BREAKUP OF TICKET MASTER
OVER THE FIASCO.
THE BIDEN DOJ SEEMS TO AGREE,
AND THEY ARE SAID TO BE
INVESTIGATING TICKET MASTER'S
PARENT COMPANY LIVE NATION AND
WHETHER THEY HAVE ABUSED THEIR
POWER IN THE LIVE MUSIC
INDUSTRY.
THAT GROUP'S CEO LAYS THE BLAME
ON TAYLOR SWIFT.
>> REALITY IS IT'S A FUNCTION OF
THE MASSIVE DEMAND THAT TAYLOR
SWIFT HAS.
THE SITE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
OPENED UP FOR 1.5 MILLION
VERIFIED TAYLOR SWIFT FANS.
WE HAD 14 MILLION PEOPLE HIT THE
SITE, INCLUDING BOTS, ANOTHER
STORY, WHICH ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE THERE.
>> Harris: ALL RIGHT, YOUR TOP
LINE THOUGHTS?
>> Will: I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S
LAYING BLAME AT TAYLOR SWIFT BUT
COMPLIMENTING HER.
14 MILLION PEOPLE TRIED TO BUY
TICKETS.
I COULD HAVE SOLD OUT 900
STADIUMS IN THE TIME WE OPENED
UP THIS TICKET BUYING PROCESS
FOR TAYLOR SWIFT.
THERE'S A LOT OF SWIFTIES.
BUT I WILL SAY I CAN'T HELP BUT
NOTICE THIS, I'M ONLY NOTICING
THIS SO LIVE NATION IS OWNED BY
LIBERTY MEDIA.
LIBERTY MEDIA CEO IS JOHN
MALONE.
HE'S GONE ABOUT THE PROCESS OF
DE-WOKE FIOING HIS COMPANIES,
BAT GIRL OUT.
MOST OF THIS HAS BEEN MADE SANE
ONCE AGAIN UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
LIBERTY MEDIA.
ONCE YOU LET GO OF SOMETHING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAD CONTROL OF,
YOU START GETTING THREATS OF FTC
LETTERS.
ASK ELON MUSK.
ALL OF A SUDDEN IF YOU LOSE
CONTROL, THE GOVERNMENT WANTS TO
TAKE A LOOK AND I SEE THAT AMAY
KLOBUCHAR AND A FEW OF THEM WANT
TO LOOK INTO TICKET MASTER, WHAT
ELSE DOES LIBERTY OWN?
THEY JUST BOUGHT CNN AND CNN IS
GOING THROUGH A PROCESS OF
DE-WOKEIFICATION AS WELL AND
THERE'S THREATS OF, I DON'T
KNOW, ANTITRUST LOOKING UNDER
THE HOOD.
IT'S AN OBSERVATION BUT SEEMS TO
BE A CORRELATION.
THERE'S A RIME, I DON'T KNOW IF
REPEATS BUT THERE'S A RHYTHM
HERE.
>> Harris: THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED THEY WANT
TO LOOK AT ANTITRUST.
>> THIS PROBE PREDATES WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE.
THAT'S NOT BECAUSE OF THIS.
I DON'T THINK -- I UNDERSTAND I
WOULD BE THE ONE AT THE TABLE TO
THINK THERE'S NOT SOME WOKE
POLITICAL CONSPIRACY THEORY
GOING ON HERE, BUT I THINK THAT
TAYLOR SWIFT FANS CRASHED THE
SITE.
>> Jeanine: DID YOU JUST CALL
THAT >> Jeanine: --
>> THEY HAVE A MONOPOLY ON THIS
AND IT GOES BACK TO 2010 AND I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT WAS THE CASE.
THEY'RE IN COMPLETE CONTROL OF
THIS AND TAYLOR SWIFT HAS A LONG
HISTORY EVEN THOUGH SHE'S A
YOUNG LADY GOING AFTER BIG
COMPANIES THAT DON'T TREAT
ARTISTS FAIRLY AND TREAT FANS
FAIRLY AND TOOK SPOTIFY ON,
APPLE MUSIC ON AND PEOPLE THAT
BENEFITED, THE FANS AND SOLO
ARTISTS WHO HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING
TO GET THEIR MUSIC HEARD TO GET,
YOU KNOW, AMPLIFICATION FOR WHAT
THEY'RE CREATING.
>> Harris: WHAT ABOUT THE
CEO'S ARGUMENT AND OTHERS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THE BOTS AMONG
THOSE 14 MILLION THAT SHE WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE PERSON TO VET ALL
OF THAT, SHE AND HER TEAM SHOULD
HAVE BEEN THE PEOPLE TO VET
THAT?
>> Jeanine: WELL, THERE'S SOME
WHO THINK BY DESIGNATING TAYLOR
SWIFT FANS, THOSE FANS ASSUME
THAT THEY HAD EARLY ACCESS
BECAUSE THEY PAID EXTRA TO BE A
VERIFIED FAN.
WHEN THEY TRIED TO GET ON THE
EARLY ACCESS, APPARENTLY BOTS
WERE DOING THE SAME THING AND
THAT'S WHEN IT STARTED TO CRASH.
IT REALLY MAYBE AS SIMPLE AS
THIS IS A CONCERT OF A LEVEL
THAT THE BEATLES HAD 30, 40
YEARS AGO.
THIS WAS HUGE: AND, YOU KNOW, TO
BE FAIR, I MEAN, THE TRUTH IS
THAT SHE'S GOT SO MANY FANS AS
THEY SAID, WE COULD HAVE FILLED
900 STADIUMS SO THE ISSUE IS
ALMOST NOT -- YOU CAN'T BLAME
ONE OR THE OTHER.
IF WE BREAK UP -- IF WE SAY IT'S
A MONOPOLY AND BREAK UP TICKET
MASTER, SOMEBODY ELSE WILL COME
IN AND SAY, YOU KNOW, WE'LL
CHARGE LESS AND THEN THE
SCALPERS COME IN AND THEY THEN
BUY THOSE TICKETS SO THE EFFORT
TO SELL TICKETS CHEAPER ENDS UP
MORE EXPENSIVE BECAUSE OVERSCALE
PERS GETTING IN THE WAY.
>> Harris: WHAT ARE WE PAYING
FOR BECAUSE THE FEES ARE HIGH?
>> Jesse: I PRO SCALPERS AND
THEY'RE DOING GREAT AND I WANT
TO GIVE THEM A HAND.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT TAYLOR IS
GOING THROUGH BECAUSE I WENT
THROUGH SOMETHING SIMILAR.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW THIS,
HARRIS, BUT I WROTE A BEST
SELLING BOOK CALLED HOW I SAVED
THE WORLD.
WHEN IT LAUNCHED, WE HAD SUCH
A --
>> Harris: WAS IT JUST YOUR
WORLD OR EVERYBODY ELSE'S?
>> Jesse: FOLLOW ALONG, IT WAS
A POWERFUL LAUNCH AND SOLD TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF COPIES IN THE
FIRST TWO WEEKS.
MY PUBLISHERS DIDN'T EXPECT THAT
JESSE WAT TERS WOULD SELL AS
MANY BOOKS.
I KNEW, BUT WE HAD TO RUN MORE
PRINTS AND TEMPORARILY WE WERE
OUT OF COPIES AND I WAS LIVID
AND KNOW HOW TAYLOR FEELS
BECAUSE WHEN YOUR FANS CAN'T GET
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DELIVER
AND IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT, IT'S
THE BIG MAN'S FAULT, THEY NEED
TO DO SOMETHING.
>> Harris: WORKING WITH A
COMPANY LIKE TICKET MASTER,
YOU'RE PAYING PRETTY HIGH FEES,
WHICH IS DIFFERENT THAN IF I BUY
YOUR BOOK ONLINE OR A BOOKSTORE.
I'M NOT GOING THROUGH TICKET
MASTER TO GET THEM.
MY QUESTION IS -- >> Jesse: I
WOULD GIVE YOU A FREE COPY.
>> Harris: THANK YOU.
IT IS YOUR WORLD.
MY QUESTION IS, WELL HOW DOES IT
WORK?
WHAT ARE YOU PAYING FOR?
WHAT AM I PAYING TICKET MASTER
AND SOME OF THE OTHERS.
THEY'RE NOT THE ONLY ONES THAT
DO THE VIVID SEATS.
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE GO AND
CHARGE THESE FEES.
ARE THEY NOT VETTING WHO THE
BOTS ARE.
WHO'S DOING THEIR JOB?
>> Will: I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
WAS BOTS VERSUS BIG FANS THAT
TAYLOR AND JESSE SHARE BUT TO
YOUR POINT REALLY QUICKLY ON
MONOPOLIES, THIS WAS TICKET
MASTER DOING A SOLID FOR THEIR
COMPETITOR.
THEIR COMPETITOR WAS THE ONE
THAT HAD THE BUSINESS AND DEFER
IT HAD OUT TO TICKET MASTER
BECAUSE THEIR SERVICE WAS BETTER
APPARENTLY.
THEIR COMPETITOR THOUGHT THEY
SERVICE WAS BETTER.
NO ONE WAS GOOD ENOUGH FOR
TAYLOR SWIFT APPARENTLY.
>> Harris: OR JESSE.
DID THEY PRINT ENOUGH BOOKS AND
COME BAC